[Music]
welcome to session 60 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series in this one
we are going to be looking at olaf
stapleton a new author to us and two of
his novels in particular the last and
first men and star maker which are
available in this single volume he wrote
quite a bit more but those are the two
that we're going to
focus on so before we get started for
anybody who's new and anybody who wants
to celebrate with us i mean it's pretty
amazing that we've gotten to
60 sessions of the worlds of speculative
fiction and you know just a review for
those of you who've been with us this
whole time and for anybody else who's
joining us anew what is the worlds of
speculative fiction series well it
started out as a set of face-to-face
lectures and discussions
that were hosted by the brookfield
public library shortly after we've moved
back here to
the city of milwaukee brookfield is a
suburb of milwaukee
and we pitched this
series that would be about
fantasy and science fiction and horror
and other modes of speculative fiction
and there were two really key components
to it other than you know giving a talk
and having some discussion so one of
them is that it involves looking at
world building across a number of
different
works so you know great example of this
tolkien's lord of the rings and the
hobbit and the cinema one of the first
ones that we began with or c.s lewis's
space trilogy
or you know george r martin's
song of ice and fire got multiple works
and we look at the world building and
what's going into that and then we also
focused quite heavily
on philosophical themes that would come
up within these works and now why am i
doing all of this rehashing
well olive stapleton
was
a
a philosopher he actually taught
philosophy wrote a number of
philosophical works including books but
also a number of articles and that stuff
flowed into his novels which he thought
were
maybe a better way of getting traction
getting his ideas
out there
and being considered than just writing
philosophy books and he was living at a
time when he thought that doing
philosophy in a public way philosophy
that could reach a broad public was
particularly important a lot of this
writing is taking place in between the
two world wars
so you know this is really i think a
central thing uh for the worlds of
speculative fiction series now back to
the the story
so we we continued for the first year
and we did a lot of you know cool uh
worlds and authors and texts and then we
got renewed for a second season you
could say and it just kept going on and
on and on until we
hit covid and the lockdowns in
uh 2020 and then you know we didn't do
any of it for a while and then i started
thinking people started asking hey are
you going to do something with this
series is it just dead in the water and
i thought well
i could just shoot it here
and do things a little bit differently
do about maybe an hour and a half of
lecture you know to the audience about
the sort of things that we would
typically cover
and then we would have a zoom session
for video conferencing for maybe another
hour and a half afterwards and some of
the people who used to come to the
brookfield sessions began participating
as well as people
in all sorts of other places including
you know in africa and europe and
south america north america
mostly a matter of time zone i think and
so it's it the series has continued on
and we did a lot of other
new authors went back to some old
authors
and people have been asking me for a
very very long time
why don't you do all of stapleton and i
you know at first i was like you know i
think i've heard that name
but i've never read anything by the guy
i better check out who he is and so i
looked online and he seemed kind of
interesting and
you know i had him lined up for
a couple times and then it just kind of
fell through and then finally this year
2022 i was like now we got to do
stapleton we got to finally get around
to this
and so i got my hands on on this and i
got a copy of his the modern theory of
ethics one of his
non-fiction you know straight philosophy
books and i read a few of his articles
as well
and a number of different things that
were said about the guy and so you know
we're going to talk about the stuff that
we usually do in these series we'll talk
about his biography we'll talk a bit
about the reception of his works we'll
talk about the world building which is
rather unique
in these two
novels
in part because you could say in some
respect they're more world building
than novel so we'll talk also about is
his work really science fiction or does
it have to have a different
classification then we'll talk about a
number of different philosophical themes
that are coming up in his works
i'm actually going to make use of a
let's call it rhetorical strategy that
stapleton himself uses over and over
again in these two novels and i'm
guessing in some of his other works as
well because i haven't read the other uh
novels
he he will often say you know i could
linger
and
digress about the
the
life of these people here or the
conversations that they had or what was
going on but we're going to like skip
over it just do things at a very very
high
level of generality right we're going to
do a grand sweep and so that's part of
what i am going to take the license to
do
in this exposition here of stapleton and
i will say something right off the bat
so
i found these two novels to be
rather of a what we call a slog right
it's not
super fascinating reading where you're
going from page to page you're like oh
my god what's happening next well i
can't believe what these characters are
doing this i gotta find out what's
what's going on right it's not a page
turner in that way as a matter of fact
you know it's fairly small print
for you know around uh well we got 434
pages between the two novels and because
there aren't
really a lot of characters there's only
a few actually
in the first novel the last and first
men and
there's there are a few characters in
star maker
um
but not an awful lot it's mostly about
like
the development of rational beings i
mean we could say we could call it human
development if we want for reasons that
we'll talk about a little bit later but
let's just call it the development and
decline the the rise decline you know
the development the
conflicts the successes and failures of
rational beings throughout the the
universe uh in in the second one and
specifically of the human races
in the first one
um
it's
it's not the kind of work i think that a
lot of people who are used to
the sci-fi genre
would necessarily find
very
attractive very compelling you know
dragging them along
through the story but if you're
interested in philosophical ideas and
you're interested in like the broad
conception of what you know
philosophical topics what is the
universe really about and what makes us
human and are we you know on the rise
are we declining you know how do we deal
with the problems that we face as not
just societies but as an entire human
race well then i think you'll probably
find these works
pretty interesting and you know they
were
well regarded in in their time and
influential on a number of other
sci-fi authors
so
you know they're well worth going into
it is a bit of an acquired taste
probably the more
philosophically oriented you are
um the more interesting you will find
them but let's uh that's probably enough
to say about uh stapleton's novels at
the beginning let's talk next uh about
his biography we'll do a little bit of a
digression because i think that tells
you why he wrote these novels and it
gives you you know some sense of who the
guy was and then we'll talk about the
world building itself and the vast sweep
of cosmic time
that is involved and then we'll go into
a number of important philosophical
themes but like i said you know we're
going to make use of his own rhetorical
dodge of just hitting on a few high
notes we're not going to try to do
something absolutely comprehensive
because that would take many more hours
than we have
for
this particular
discussion
with an author like ola stapleton we
have to look at his biography to some
degree in order to
situate these these two novels
in particular that we're looking at but
also his other works which comprise a
you could say connected
body whether they're his
science fiction works or
his non-fiction works or indeed his uh
early poetry
and the other things that he's doing
as well because he is a philosopher as
well as a novelist
and short story writer
so his story begins in 1886
he's born to william klibitz stapleton
and emmeline mill
and the family is living a good bit of
time in his first six years in port
saeed egypt and you might say well why
is that the case he's actually born in
england
but his his family
his grandfather established a shipping
company that's going back and forth
between liverpool and port saeed and
that's going to play a role later on in
his life
in 1903 he meets this australian cousin
agnes zena miller who's later on going
to assume an important role
in his life
and by 8 1908 he is publishing essays so
he is
um you know
in his his uh early 20s
um he
goes to school and then he goes off to
oxford and it's while he's at um
and i'm probably mispronouncing this uh
baleaul uh college oxford
where he's gonna earn his his bachelor
in modern history in 1909 that's where
he begins doing his first writings
then he begins working in the shipping
offices for
this company
both in liverpool and in port saeed in
the family business he doesn't appear to
have been particularly interested
in that or particularly diligent and in
1912 he begins a new job
working for the liverpool branch of the
workers educational association so he's
already engaging in some educational
work as somebody who just has a college
degree
a year later in 1913 he earns his
master's also from oxford and then of
course you notice what's gonna happen
immediately the first world war and by
this time you know stapleton has uh sort
of organized his thoughts about things
he's a pacifist he's a conscientious
objector but he's not a coward so by
1915 he is actually out there in belgium
and he joins the quaker funded friends
ambulance unit and becomes an ambulance
driver now that's a pretty dangerous job
he will eventually earn the quad gear
for bravery
you know which is i think pretty easy to
display
if you have it if you're an ambulance
driver because you've got to go and get
the wounded in one of the bloodiest wars
in history
the war ends
i should point out too that in 1914
he does
author
something called latter-day psalms and
these are poetry he is not a christian
but he's going to write some sort of you
know
poetry that that are connected to
religion we'll talk about that a bit
more so in in 1919 he finally leaves the
service obviously the war ends in with
armistice in 1918 but that doesn't mean
that everybody goes home
right away so he does come home and then
he
marries this cousin of his agnes zena
miller and they live in britain
they have a daughter mary who is born in
1920 and in 1923 his son john is born
and you know he continues working and
then he earns in 1925
a phd in philosophy
from the university of liverpool so you
notice that he's going from oxford to
liverpool
and you know this this allows him to to
work on his his uh degree while he's
also a working person and you know
engaging with the family life and he
begins lecturing now this is where the
story i think gets really really
interesting
so
stapleton is
a professor of philosophy
but he's not an ordinary professor of
philosophy he's not one of these stuffy
sorts who is in the you know the ivory
tower as we say
he actually teaches in what is called
the extramural department now what does
the extramural mean outside of the walls
outside of the
university and he teaches philosophy
english literature industrial history
and psychology so he's teaching not just
regular college students but what we
would nowadays call continuing education
or
working people and stuff like that so he
is already doing something that's rather
unusual and he's also engaging in what
nowadays
we call public philosophy he's giving
lectures to all sorts of clubs and
organizations on a variety of important
topics in 1928 uh his revised
dissertation a modern theory of ethics a
study of the relations of ethics and
psychology quite an interesting work
i've read it i've enjoyed it
is published and in 1930 he publishes
the last and first men so he publishes a
a book of ethics a book of philosophy
and then he publishes this
novel of incredible scope and you can
say what's going on there well
stapleton thought that he had a better
chance of reaching a much wider audience
by writing fiction or as he's going to
say a little bit later when we look at
what he says in the forward of that
creating
myths
and
this allows him to you know decide to
become a full-time writer as well as to
teach
so
1930 last and first men we see a
follow-up to this in 1932 with the last
men in london which is not quite as
great a
novel in 1934 it publishes another
non-fiction work waking world and in
1935 he publishes another novel that
we're not going to talk about
here because i haven't read it but it's
worth pointing out it is called
odd john a story between just and
earnest and the theme of that one is a
bit different than star maker and um
last and first men it has to do with a
superman
in in our world
and
how he would fit in with
society so it's taking on some of the
you know ideas of the time
then in 1937 we have star maker
published right
and in
1939 he publishes quite a few works
saints and revolutionaries new hope for
britain philosophy and living and as we
know the you know the second great war
between uh at the very start
germany uh versus poland uh and then
france and and britain come in on the
side of poland poland is is cut apart by
germany and the soviet union and it
begins the second world war and even
though he's a pacifist even though he
was a conscientious objector in the
previous war
stapledon
says we need to fight the nazis we need
to fight against fascism there there's
certain lines that have been crossed
and so he supports the war effort
against nazi germany he also he had
always been sort of on on the side of
the left and he becomes an advocate in
1942 of the newly formed as it's often
described libertarian socialist
commonwealth movement and party
and he publishes at that time darkness
and the light
another fiction work and beyond the isms
which is kind of an interesting piece as
well
in you know the war goes on in 1944 he
publishes seven pillars of peace you
notice that he's already very interested
in thinking about what would be the
conditions of world peace and he
publishes the old man
in new world
and then the war comes to an
end 1946 he publishes youth and tomorrow
and the fiction worked death into life
1947 another fiction work the flames of
fantasy
and then in 1948 he's traveling around
speaking at a lot of important places
including the world congress of
intellectuals for peace in poland
he also publishes interplanetary man
1949 he speaks at the conference for
world peace held in new york city and in
1950 he actually becomes involved with
the south african anti-apartheid
movement he speaks in paris france he's
supposed to speak in yugoslavia but has
to cancel that returns home
sick and dies of a heart attack but
publishes a man divided
at that time and there's a few of his
works that are published posthumously
the opening of the eyes for encounters
east is west and
you know it's it's not that long
of a life but he's he's you know
spending a lot of time engaging in you
know
working as a public intellectual
and doing so in ways that
feed into
some of the themes of these these two
great novels i do want to read you
because you know we want to talk about
the
the motive for
writing these well he tells us them
in his preface
uh to each of them and so
he says in the preface to
the last and first men this is a work of
fiction i have tried to invent a story
which may seem a possible or at least
not wholly
impossible account of the future of man
i've tried to make that story relevant
to the change that's taking place today
in man's outlook
and he goes on and says
that to romance of the future may seem
to be indulgence and ungoverned
speculation for the sake of the
marvelous but controlled imagination
this fear
can be a very valuable exercise for
minds bewildered about the present and
its potentialities today we should
welcome and even study every serious
attempt to envisage the future of our
race not merely in order to grasp the
very diverse and often tragic
possibilities that confront us
but also that we may familiarize
ourselves with the certainty that many
of our own most cherished ideals would
seem purell to more developed minds to
to romance of the far future then is to
attempt to see the human race in its
cosmic setting
and to mold our hearts
to entertain new values
he goes on a little bit further and he
says our aim is not merely to create
aesthetically admirable fiction we must
achieve neither mere history
nor mere fiction
but myth
a true myth is one which within the
universe of a certain culture
expresses richly and perhaps tragically
the highest admirations possible within
that culture a false myth
is one which either violently
transgresses the limits of credibility
set by its own cultural matrix or
expresses admiration less developed than
those of its culture's best vision this
book can no more claim to be true myth
than true prophecy but it is an essay in
myth creation
that is what he's attempting to to do
here in um star maker which is
written you know closer to
the beginning of world war
ii
he begins his preface by saying this at
a moment when europe is in danger of a
catastrophe worse than that of 1914 a
book like this may be condemned as a
distraction from the desperately urgent
defense
of civilization against modern
barbarism year by year month by month
the plight of our fragmentary and
precarious civilization becomes more
serious fascism abroad grows more bold
and ruthless in its foreign ventures
more tyrannical towards its own citizens
more barbarian in its contempt for the
life of the mind even in our own country
we have reason to fear a tendency
towards militarization and the
curtailment of civil liberty moreover
while the decades pass no resolute step
is taken to alleviate the injustice of
our social order our outworn economic
system dooms millions
to frustration and he says in these
conditions it's difficult for writers to
pursue their calling at once with
courage and with balanced judgment some
merely shrug their shoulders and
withdraw
from the central struggle of our age
these with their minds closed against
the world's most vital issues inevitably
produce works which not only have no
depth of significance for their
contemporaries but are also subtly
insecure and
he goes on and he says i have a sympathy
with some of those intellectuals who
declare they have no useful contribution
to make to the struggle and therefore it
better not dabble in it i
in fact am one of them in our defense i
should say that though we are inactive
or ineffective as direct supporters of
the cause we do not ignore it indeed it
constantly obsessively holds our
attention
and so you know he goes on and he and he
says that
um
[Music]
here we go
at the risk of raising thunder on both
the left and the right i haven't
occasionally used certain ideas and
words derived from religion and i have
tried to interpret them in relation to
modern needs the valuable though much
damaged words spiritual and worship
which have become almost as obscene to
the left as the good old sexual words
are to the right are here intended to
suggest an experience which the right is
apt to pervert and the left to
misconceive this experience i should say
involves detachment from all private all
social all racial ends not in the sense
that it leads a man to reject them but
it makes him prize them
in a new
way
this enterprise who goes on can lead us
to an increased lucidity and finer
temper of consciousness and therefore
can have a great and beneficial effect
on behavior indeed if this supremely
humanizing experience does not produce
along with a kind of piety towards fate
the resolute will to serve our waking
humanity it is a mere sham
and a snare so there we have his partial
descriptions of his own projects that we
see him
carrying out through fiction and also
through non-fiction philosophy i would
like to point out one other thing before
we close this biographical section
he also wrote many articles as i've
discovered
within philosophy he didn't just write
books he contributed to academic
philosophy in quite interesting ways
that we can talk about
elsewhere
so that's uh some of stapleton's
background we should talk now
about his world building
i had mentioned earlier that world
building is working in somewhat of a
different manner in ola stapleton's
novels the last and first men and star
maker
and if we think about what world
building does typically in
sci-fi fantasy horror speculative
fiction
in general whether it's you know
fairly
minimal or whether
it is you know super elaborate and in
the way of like a tolkien
or a
r scott backer or somebody like that
what's happening usually with world
building
is there's a you know a lot of thought
given to developing the narrative
universe in which things are taking
place
and a lot of that is you know really
cool stuff but it's there
to provide a setting to provide a milieu
for the characters to do and say things
to have you know conflicts to
fight each other to overcome obstacles
and you know there's usually some back
history and there's some development
going on as well so plot takes place
within the framework of the world that
has been built or is in the process of
being continually built and you know the
plot is part of the history and the
characters are also part of the world so
there's a very complex dynamic and
dialectical interrelation between them
now stapleton's works are a bit
different there aren't a lot of
characters there's you know there's a
main
character in star maker the narrator
right who it very quickly winds up being
connected with other minds who then come
along for
the
uh
ride free free of space and time
checking out all these different
cultures
and almost all of them are unnamed
there's also a few characters in last
and first men there's a prophet at one
point there's this great you know uh
contest between the representative of
you know a much later
chinese and a much later american
empires right
but for the most part there aren't there
aren't a lot of characters the the
characters if there are
anything that we want to call characters
they are entire
races
of
human beings or you know other rational
beings that are going to be called
rational beings so
you know going back to thinking about
world building and other
authors works we often have a lot of
geography sometimes with maps we have
you know development of a depiction of
cultures
we have languages sometimes being worked
out certainly names that have some sort
of commonality to them and have
connotations sometimes they'll actually
go into the economics of it
some more than others and there's you
know usually some some history going on
that's
happened that's important for the
present
there's technology or magic or whatever
else is being added to things and
sometimes the world building is like an
elaboration of the world that we inhabit
and sometimes it's like its own
world you know think about andre
norton's witch world right starts out
very
early on with a guy here
in
earth and then it quickly gets
transposed into the witch world and and
all of that sort of stuff happens there
or um
philip jose farmer's world of tears in
which it's revealed that earth is just
one
pocket universe of many that were
developed by
these you know creatures that are like
us human beings but are very powerful
and ancient called the lords right or
you know if you think about um uh hp
lovecraft's uh cthulhu stuff we have we
have the earth of our place and it's
sort of like tails from the dark side
you know there's there's the surface
level that most people live in and then
there's the dark side which is you know
just as real but not as brightly lit in
which elder beings can you know invade
our universe and stuff like that so you
know that's the typical kind of world
building stapleton is like
turning things on on their head without
meaning to
the world building
is
the plot in a certain way you could say
right
and it's
you know sometimes more explicit and
sometimes less so what we see being
depicted here
in these stories is the
transformation the changes the conflicts
the
seeking after
greater things the descent into
madness and pathological
individualism or you know some kind of
fascism or pick whatever else you you
want
um
you know there's a transformation that's
taking place
you could say physiologically of the
beings themselves there's transformation
geographically
and planet-wise and in you know star
maker even to some degree in last and
first men there's you know
transformation of entire solar systems
or of
much larger
uh
systems in play so you know you've got
the transformation of the bodies of
beings you've got the transformation of
the
ecology and the uh interplanetary and
then you know interstellar systems
and you have transformation of society
and culture and mindsets and stuff like
that and the rising and falling and
facing challenges and all of those are
parts of
world
and that is what these two novels
chart out uh so it's world building as a
dynamic process you might say uh and it
gets into an incredibly
cosmic scale in star maker where by the
end they're you know it's like the whole
universe is being interconnected and
they're seeking out the the generator
the creator the originator of all of
this the star
maker and it's
an intergalactic
civilization that's doing that that's
seeking and so you know there's
some pretty cosmic scope going on in
here and this leads us to um one of the
first philosophical themes i think
how can stapleton
tell us that kind of story so i want to
say one thing right off the bat which is
that um
stapleton for
you know whatever
criticisms you may make of him
has an incredibly
fertile imagination and it's not just
imagination but sort of like a
combination of imagination creative
imagination
and intellect put together at the same
time
working out uh you know society after
society human race after human race
in all these myriad ways
now he does oftentimes beg off and say
well i can't tell you too much more
about this because that would like as he
says at one point generated an entire
library rather than a book
but what he does give us is incredibly
varied and
fertile and
you know this these will make you think
quite a lot about the possibilities for
our own human civilization and us as
groups and individuals so that's one
side
but there's an even more important issue
that arises and it's a narrative issue
and it's also a philosophical
specifically epistemological issue
how can the narrator actually know the
things that they're
narrating how can the author
you know in a narrative sense pretend to
be
a being who can tell these stories that
are covering incredibly long
periods of time
you know
are they a historian of time past well
how do they know about this stuff then
and here is where we get to a really
interesting
plot device
we can call it the overcoming of space
and time
and in the
first novel the last and first men this
is happening towards the
the end of the human races which now
humanity is on neptune because you know
the world the earth has been a long
since rendered uninhabitable as has been
venus as has mars and now they're out on
neptune and the human race has changed
quite a lot
and so um here's a little passage
we've watched the fortunes of eight
successive human species for a thousand
million years the first half of that
flicker which is the duration of man ten
more species now succeed one another or
our contemporary on the plains of
neptune
we the last men are the 18th men of the
eight pre-neptunian species
some
as we have seen remained always
primitive many achieved at least a
confused and fleeting civilization one
the brilliant fifth was already
awakening into true humanity when
misfortune crushed it the the ten
newtonian species shown even greater
diversity they range from instinctive
animal to modes of consciousness never
uh before attained the definitively
sub-human degenerate types are confined
mostly to the first 600 million years of
man sojourn on neptune during the
earlier half of this long phase of
preparation man at first almost crushed
out of existence by a hostile
environment gradually people the huge
north but with beasts not men and he
goes on right so these are some really
really long periods now
how
how does he know that how can the the
18th men
have any idea of this well they have
overcome
the um confines
of time
right and he talks about the
the racial mind transcending the minds
of groups and individuals and
philosophical insight into the true
nature
of space and time mind and its objects
cosmical striving and cosmic cosmical
perfection and you know he goes on and
he tells us
that um you know there's this whole
racial experience that they can
access
from their their particular sets of
men and then you know he goes on and he
tells us that
they're able to go back
into
all of the previous
races and
you know sort of so to speak recall or
remember
what is
going on as individuals he says we can
hold within one now a duration equal to
the old terrestrial day and within that
duration we can if we will discriminate
rapid pulsations such as commonly we
hear together as a high musical tone as
the race mind we perceived is now the
whole period since the birth of the
oldest living individuals and the whole
past of the species appeared as a
personal memory stretching back into the
midst of infancy but if we wanted to we
could discriminate within the now one
light vibration from the next so they
can they can go back in in time
and
hear see sense what's going on
in um star maker
we have a disembodied mind from england
who winds up going out into the cosmos
and you know hooks up with this this
philosopher on another planet and then
they begin spending time searching
through the galaxy and he says
along with freedom of space we had
freedom of time some of the worlds we
explored in this early phase of our
adventure
ceased to exist long before my native
planet was formed others were its
contemporaries other were not others
were not born until the old age of our
galaxy when the earth had been destroyed
and a large number of the stars had
already been extinguished
as we searched up and down space and
time discovering more and more of the
rare grains called planets as we watched
race after race struggle to a certain
degree of lucid consciousness only to
succumb to some external accident or
more often to some flaw in its own
nature it goes on right so
they're able to watch like entire
worlds and
species which he's willing to call human
another theme will pick up in a bit
develop
advance decline
they're able to
overcome
the problems of
you know distance
and
temporal
separation
and you know
he goes on
this is much later on when he's talking
about the community of worlds the last
and most difficult power to be obtained
to be attained by those worlds in the
course of their utopian phase was
psychical freedom of space and time the
limited power to observe directly and
even to contribute to events remote from
the spatiotemporal location of the
observer
throughout our explorations we had been
greatly perplexed by the fact that we
most of whom were beings of a very
humble order should have been able to
achieve this freedom which we now
discovered
the these highly developed worlds found
so difficult to master the explanation
was given to us and here's another
interesting theme
no such venture as ours could have been
undertaken by our unaided selves
throughout our exploration we had
unwittingly been under the influence of
a system of worlds which had attained
this freedom only after eons of research
not one step could have been taken
without the constant support of those
brilliant ichthyoid and arachnoid
symbiotics who played a leading part in
the history of our galaxy the freedom of
space and time the power of cosmical
exploration and of influence by means of
telepathic contact was at once the most
potent and the most dangerous asset of
the fully awakened utopian
worlds and so you know i'm not going to
linger on the dangers and the
opportunities but what does this allow
in terms of the world building and the
narrative exposition
it's you know
it's not scientifically explained
although stapleton does know the science
of his time quite well
um but it's assumed to be something that
a a later civilization much more
advanced than our own
would in fact acquire and
retrospectively
not only can they observe what happened
in the past they can influence it so
they can give the narrator
in star maker the chance to him and and
the others that you know hang out with
him and become disembodied minds uh
going along the opportunity to overcome
space and time and then to tell us
the stories in an of course very atom
braided way
within these novels a rather ingenious
way
of
you know on the one hand
um
[Music]
overcoming that epistemological problem
how could they possibly know that stuff
and then you know how could they
communicate it to us
and also a you might say narrative
framing problem and so you know
this is all
part of the backdrop you could say or
the necessary condition
for the world building that is so
absolutely central to these stories
before turning ourselves in a much more
deliberate way and looking at the text
and the philosophical themes that are
not just arising or in the background
but you know front and center in these
two novels last and first men in star
maker
i do want to touch a little bit more
broadly on
what stapleton himself made of the genre
that he's working in and what other
people have made
of his work and his commitments
that we can see coming up in
not just uh his his fiction work but
also his non-fiction work and indeed the
way he lived his life so i think if we
if we look first at his views on
politics
and religion that might be a good place
to start
you know stapleton
was on the left but not a marxist he
actually thought that marxist and
christianity
properly understood had some things in
common and he was willing to take
whatever good came out of either
one of those and in in a piece called
new hope for britain a book right he
actually um
looks at the four main british political
parties trying to figure out what he can
take take from them and this is coming
from an article all of stapleton utopia
in warship by vincent
geogen so geogen says and he's
excerpting here in part
that
these elements the the precious elements
are not the exclusive property of
particular parties they can be found in
a number of the traditions from the
conservative party so the furthest right
in this case he digs out a belief in the
english spirit which he defines as a
spirit of mutual respect between
friendly organizers and though those
whom they organize between equals and
between the humbler and more responsible
workers for the common wheel
in the case of the liberal party
stapleton applauds its historic
fundamental value the intrinsic value of
the individual human being
conceived at best as a defense of
individual autonomy against both tyranny
and conformism the labor party has a
grasp of the central importance of the
social that the social environment molds
individual minds and that is a
consequence the economic and the social
need to be under the control of the
people and then finally in the case of
the communist party there is the strong
commitment to revolution and to the
creation of a new society based on
comradeship so is it you know you notice
that stapleton is
committed on one side but he's willing
to take whatever
is good in the
other
the other groups the other sides
in another piece which is um
called the great certainty
which i'm only going to read parts of
here he's looking at
religion and
stapleton was an agnostic he was not an
atheist because he thought that that
actually goes too far and is is
it represents a commitment that can't
really be justified he's also not a
theist certainly not a christian but
he's willing to say there's there's
probably
something that we find in religion that
could be humanized that could be
purified and so here's what he says
there are three kinds of activity
distinctive of personality which in the
actual experience of them i perceive to
be supremely good or right having this i
have not only to describe the three
activities and the nature of personality
but also to show that the little words
good and right have intelligible meaning
for the moment i will leave over this
abstract ethical problem and let good
and right be interpreted as the reader
chooses
the three kinds of activity
may be
roughly named
intelligence
love
and creative action
it is tempting to call them the
distinctively human or personal forms of
cognition
affection
and con
carnation which are the three aspects of
consciousness but intelligence love and
creative action involve all three of
these abstract aspects of consciousness
for each of them includes in some degree
the other they are indeed merely factors
in the unitary conscious life of
creatures that have obtained to some
measure of personality sometimes one and
sometimes another factor is more obvious
we may speak of an act of intelligence
or of love or of creativeness but in
truth intelligence
is never loveless
and it is always to a greater lesser
extent creative love is never wholly
blind undiscriminating unintelligent and
is always mentally creative and creation
in whatever sphere
involves some degree of intelligence
and
some kind of loving
he goes on and he says the three names i
have chosen must be interpreted very
broadly intelligence must be taken to
include all discriminative sensitivity
he goes on as well
and says the word love must be
understood to include every kind of
valuing of anything not as a means but
disinterestedly for its own sake the
third intrinsically good activity is
creative action by this phrase i mean
every kind of consciously directed
activity which is and results in
something significantly
novel
and so this is what he thinks is there
in
religion when religion is doing its job
right when
humankind is oriented religiously to
things but it's not just
in religion it can be in in the life of
you know the mind it can be in
technology it can be in social
organization it can be in political
dispute it can be in all sorts of
manners so i think this is quite
important you know
i do want to say a few other things as
well that that start to lead us outside
of uh politics and religion per se and
into the
craft work that stapleton is involved in
um he had a correspondence with virginia
woolf
and when virginia woolf read
star maker
she uh thought that the philosophical
framework was was a little bit difficult
to understand but she wrote and she said
i've understood enough to be greatly
interested and excited to since
sometimes it seems to me you are
grasping ideas i have tried to express
much more fumblingly in fiction but you
have gone much further and i can't help
envying you
as one does those who reach
what one has aimed at and as somebody
points out in the encyclopedia of
science fiction entry on alice stapleton
stapleton is however though sometimes
dimly perceived the star maker behind
many subsequent stories of the far
future and galactic empires he did much
original and seminal thinking about such
matters as
parallel worlds colonization of other
worlds cosmology cyborgs esp hive minds
immortality monsters mutants and time
travel
and he was perhaps the first author to
introduce the concept
of the prime directive that we see in
star trek
he was influential on arthur c clarke
on stanislaus lem on cs lewis who
actually reacts against him and and
wrote the space trilogy to sort of thumb
his nose at stapleton
there's also you know something quite
interesting that jorge louis borges
said this is in a introduction to a 1965
argentinian edition of star maker
he said that stapleton's style suggests
that before writing he'd read a great
deal of philosophy and not many novels
or poems he also drew attention to
the lack of hubris and a work is all
encompassing a star maker he says
stapleton doesn't shore up inventions to
distract or stupefy the reader with an
honest rigor he pursues and retraces the
complex and obscure vicissitudes of his
coherent dream
from our contemporary vantage point star
maker is more than a prodigious novel
that is a possible and plausible
representation of the plurality of
worlds
and of their dramatic history
so quite high praise from people in the
business so to speak right of
speculative fiction
stapleton himself
didn't
originally call what he was doing
science fiction he actually called uh
what he was doing fantastic fiction of a
semi-f philosophical kind or as we saw
in the preface to first last and first
men myth making stapleton when he was um
uh asked about science fiction he said i
find myself in a bit of a whole about
science fiction i never was a fan of it
and i read very little of it i recognize
it as a legitimate medium of expression
and i think it has a future he wrote
this to a science fiction magazine and
then
in a lecture called science and fiction
he sets out
what he takes to be
the rules of the game of science fiction
all of which are directed to the demands
of fiction making and there's three
things that he he requires at that point
plausibility
achieved by the fiction's conformity to
the best current scientific knowledge in
that respect he's in line with say
stannis law lem
second the imaginative creation of
further possibilities developed by
logical extension from current ideas
and three
psychological and spiritual relevance to
human readers in the present through the
construction of quote myths of for a
scientific
age
now um
you know
this actually gives us a a a good sense
about what he's up to and you know the
third one connects him up with authors
like say ursula k le guin or
philip jose farmer or
jg ballard right
a little bit later
we find
that
he's going to come up with other
interesting rules
as well
um
but before we get to that there's
something that's coming out of ola
stapleton and the idea of science
fiction by robert uh crossley that i'd
like to bring up
so
stapleton gave all these lectures about
you know
science fiction what he's up to
here's what what crossley says the roll
call of scientifically venturesome poets
and novelists in science and literature
this lecture that he gave is the
framework for stapleton's construction
of an iconoclastic tradition of writers
who respond imaginatively imaginatively
both to words and numbers to books and
machines and who try to unify the
perspectives of the two cultures the
artists he names all seek as he says of
dante scientific versitude according to
the lights of their age
even two writers who stapleton says
display no direct influence of science
are treated as examples not of pure
fantasy but scientific method applied to
fictional procedure
rob lay's gargantua is not just a
fantastic creature but an instance of
gigantism realistically worked out the
worlds of gulliver reveal how swift
works out consequences of novel ideas
realism
and you know he brings up bacon and
butler meredith rosney abbott and vern
these form a line of prophet critics who
offer visions fancies and warnings
in fictional speculations that are
rooted in scientific discoveries and
laboratory
method
he also talks about h.g wells and
crosley says this next to wiles
stapleton was the most original
practitioner of the scientific romance
in the first half of the century
professionally trained as a philosopher
much more patient with and drawn to
abstraction than wells he ought to have
been better equipped to formulate a
theory of science fiction right and
stapleton's first novel last and first
men appeared in 1930 reviewers noticed
and overstated his work's resemblance to
wells just as wells was irritated by
being known as an english vern so
stapleton labored under the burden of
having all his most innovative works
tagged as wellesey and romances by
critics unable to find a more
accommodating pigeonhole for his
disturbing visions of far futures and
present oddities the last thing i want
to bring up is another list that and
this is coming from a lecture man's
prospects uh in 1934 stapleton considers
the uses of forecasting that is thinking
about the future how you know that
that's to come and you know stapleton by
the way is uh you know looked to by
futurists and by transhumanist as
somebody who you know is
you could say in their circle
and so
stapleton comes up with seven rules of
the game of speculation
so
what are these rules
first
up-to-date knowledge from a wide variety
of disciplines sociology astronomy
biochemistry and philosophy
second
imaginative freedom from the limits of
contemporary knowledge and the audacity
to peer beyond these limits so you
notice already we've got a dialectic
between you you know you have to start
with a good knowledge of the current
sciences but not just science also
philosophy
and then you got to go beyond
third a comprehensive and balanced
vision that avoids the
one-dimensionality
of a forecast that is merely economic
merely physical merely psychological and
so on an avoidance of reductionism
fourth a radical skepticism on the part
of the prophet who should acknowledge
the unlikelihood of all specific
anticipations of the future including
his own so however enthusiastic one
becomes you have to maintain this
attitude of skepticism
fifth an ability to define the main
questions
of the future
questions of work class leisure human
interests political organization
not just you know space opera and zap
zap and fighting the empire or something
like that or romance out in space
real human issues right
not escapism
six a commitment to pursue the
fundamental question well what is this
fundamental question
will man be more developmentally
or fallen into barbarism
a really important point then finally
seventh
working distinctions among the near
future measured in centuries the middle
future
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
years and the remote future millions and
billions of years so a kind of
difference of scope
and
distinction between what's possible in
the near future what could be happening
in the middle future and what could the
destiny of humanity or rational races as
we're going to see what could that look
like
millions of years from now so these are
some great ways to conceptualize what
what stapleton is up to particularly in
these two works but really throughout
his entire career
in my view one of the most interesting
and indeed important philosophical
themes running through these two novels
last and first men and star maker
is right there in the title of the first
novel men
and
stapleton is not using this in a
particularly gendered way he means
humanity and he means races
of humanity he's not thinking in terms
of what we often times will call race
in our own experience which is a you
know incredibly socially constructed and
historical bound up thing with all these
arbitrary divisions that isn't the same
from
country to country and culture to
culture instead we're thinking of
you know entire
species of human beings but here's the
really interesting thing
stapledon
is not
particularly interested in
distinguishing between
humans on the basis of belonging
genetically to the human race because as
we find in for example last and first
men
there are human races which are
developed by other human races
biologically right using some of the
stock
and then there are other human races
that evolve
out of animals
so
it's not
humanity in the genetic sense that
we typically think of
stapledon is willing to call
men or human beings
any
species that is intelligent
and that you know it rises beyond a
certain level and has let's say social
organization and the capacity for
intricate rational problem solving and
passing things on through culture and
perhaps even you know developing some
kind of technology or language or
something like that and you know this
could come from
any sort of living basis as a matter of
fact in star maker he even talks about
you know plants for example plant men as
being part of this at the very end we
get to the stars and they're intelligent
beings as we're going to discover
so this is a very interesting
anthropological
on his part anthropological in a
philosophical
sense and so what i thought we should do
you know in part because in order to get
a sense of what the first and last men
is about we should talk about these
different
you know first second third these
different
races
or species
of human beings
and he begins in our own time
and he charts out an interesting history
that didn't happen in our time although
we are you know
again i don't want to abuse this word
interesting
we are moving towards a world that if it
is bipolar in any respect would be
america and china and that's actually
what ends up happening
with the
the first men the first race
europe basically exhausts itself in
another war there's all sorts of things
that are going on that i don't have to
go into great detail about and
eventually it leads to a world state
um
which is you know one of our our
possibilities
and you know there's some upheavals and
breakdowns um there's a you know
environmental uh catastrophes that take
place
humanity rises again in patagonia and
you know spreads uh throughout the the
world and then you know other
catastrophes and then there's siberia
and then eventually the human race
basically
succumbs
develops
rather degenerates
into
a kind of barbarism and you know it's
millions of years before
the second men arise and interestingly
the second men
are of a you know they're they're human
in the sense that they're rational and
they have all these other human
characteristics but they're unlike us in
that they're not driven by
some of the same egotistical egocentric
desires that we ourselves are so prone
to
and they develop a nice little
civilization until they get invaded by
life forms from mars who try to colonize
the earth and eventually this is going
to lead to a catastrophe there's all
sorts of things that go on a war that
takes place um some of the martian
genetic stuff getting getting to be in
human beings sort of like how you know
we have mitochondria and all that and
leading to problems and plagues
then we have the third men arising and
these are smaller their civilization is
very focused on
music and they live a sort of a set you
know aesthetic life you could say
and they're eventually going to start
leading to a new
project that of deliberately
manipulating
life
into
a new kind of human being and they
create these new human beings that have
well they're not just they have they are
just gigantic brains
and these gigantic brains live in silos
and have connections with each other
eventually they enslave
most of the third human race and then
eventually
the fourth men these giant brains
realize their own limitations and begin
constructing a new kind of race the
fifth men who will eventually supplant
both the third and the fourth
and also colonize
venus leading to a genocide on venus of
the venetian
species
the human beings supplant them
eventually this leads to the sixth men
who are a venusian species there's also
a degeneration into this kind of
seal-like
animals as well
perhaps one of them the most fascinating
groups is the seventh men who have a
civilization that is entirely
not just avian but
ariel and
you know stapleton i've remarked before
about his incredible powers
of imagination he imagines a society in
which flight is the primary
occupation and metaphor for things
eventually this is going to lead to
realizing something has been lost and an
eighth species evolves the eighth men
who are
pedestrian compared to ariel and they
redevelop technology
and then there is a
catastrophe that's not just ecological
or environmental but solar system wide
the sun is going to start damaging the
inner planets so humanity has to adapt
and once again there's a let's make
human beings anew so that they can live
out on neptune and these are some you
know rather smallish uh beings they're
they eventually fall into savagery and
degenerate into animals a bunch of
different animal types
and then the the 10th through the 13th
arise out of this rabbit-like species
and become civilized and you know one
replaces the other in time and then we
have the 14th to the 17th who are said
to be sort of like replications
of the first men the second men and the
you know basically idealist
idyllic utopian fifth men who are so
advanced and then finally we get to the
the 18th the last men
the final species the most advanced the
ones who are telling the story
in uh last and first men
and they are a very interesting type
they have a whole bunch of different
subgenders no longer just male and
female
they they're connected together
telepathically they're essentially
immortal although you know they can kill
themselves or be destroyed you know in
accidents and stuff like that and they
live an incredibly long time until the
sun is about to go supernova and then
they have to decide what they're going
to do and they send out
they're described by stapleton as
viruses to seed
life throughout the galaxy
and you know they have already escaped
the bounds of time and space and we get
to the very end of the novel
where this is the last paragraph
one thing is certain man himself at the
very least is music a brave theme that
makes music also of its vast
accompaniment its matrix of storms and
stars man himself in his degree is
essentially a beauty in the eternal form
of things it is very good to have been
man
and so we may go forward with laughter
in our hearts and peace thankful for the
past and for our own courage for we
shall make after all a fair conclusion
to this brief music
that is man this is the 18th race right
in star maker we have even more
species and even wider
scope going on the the nameless uh
narrator he goes to the first world that
you know he's disembodied that he can
find and he finds that there are beings
that are man-like there and he's willing
to call them
the other
men
he says i had always supposed man was a
unique being an inconceivably complex
conjunction of circumstances that
produced them it was not to be supposed
that such conditions would be repeated
anywhere in the universe
yet here on the very first globe to be
explored was an obvious peasant
and he goes on and he talks you know
about observing
him and he says although evolution on
this earth-like planet must have taken a
course on the whole surprisingly like
that which had produced my own kind
there must have also been many
divergences
and he tells us about some of these you
know the the importance of the sense of
taste for them and the meaning of it for
their culture eventually he hooks up
with a philosopher with whom he starts
to explore the cosmos
and they they go to many different
worlds and uh look at many
different uh races
and species and he says uh some some
really interesting stuff this is a
little bit later
most of those worlds were near were
really no worse than our own like us
they'd reach the stage when the spirit
half awakened from brutishness very far
from maturity can suffer most
desperately and behave most cruelly and
like us these tragic but vital worlds
visited in our early adventures were
agonized by the inability of their minds
to keep pace with changing circumstances
they were always behind hand always
applying old concepts and old ideals
inappropriately to novel situations like
us they were constantly tortured by
their hunger for a degree of community
which their condition demanded but their
poor cowardly selfish spirits could by
no means attain only in couples in
little circles of companions could they
support true community the communion of
mutual insight and respect and
love but in their tribes and nations
they conceived all too easily the sham
community of the pack
being in unison of fear and hate and he
says particularly in one respect these
races were recognizably our kin
each had risen by a strange mixture of
violence
and gentleness the apostles of jet
violence and the apostles of gentleness
swayed them this way and that and at the
time of our visit many of these worlds
were in the throes of a crisis of this
conflict and you know so he tells us
this is a pattern that gets replicated
over and over again and he says
the most numerous of all classes of
intelligent worlds is that which
includes the planet familiar to readers
of this book homo sapiens has recently
flattered and frightened himself by
conceiving that though perhaps he is not
the soul intelligence in the cosmos he
is at least unique and the world suited
to intelligent life of any kind must be
extremely rare this view proves
ludicrously
false
in comparison with the unimaginable
number of the stars intelligent worlds
are indeed
very rare
but we discovered some thousands of
worlds much like the earth and possessed
by beings of essentially humankind
though superficially they were often
unlike the type that we call human the
other men were amongst the most
obviously human but in a later stage of
our adventure when our research was no
longer restricted to worlds that had
reached the familiar spiritual crisis we
stumbled on a few planets inhabited by
races almost identical with homo sapiens
or rather with the creature that homo
sapiens was in the earliest phase of his
existence
and then he goes on and talks about the
many
many other
strange mankinds to use a chapter
title and he says that you know these
all developed these humans developed
from non-human in our you know sense uh
creatures and you know there are ecnito
derms we're going to see that there's an
incredibly important role played by
these ixioids and arachnoids that wind
up in a symbiotic relation with each
other
um
and you know he goes on just describing
nautiloids you know it's almost like a
travel journal by this point
and then you know we've got the
symbiotic race described um we have the
plant men
uh composite beings
uh who are sort of like birds and and
all of that and he goes goes on and on
and on and what's important about this
all of them are
human beings in some
important sense and eventually there's
going to be a galactic
community of worlds the building of
which lies beyond the the comprehension
of the writer of this book he says and
he says that there is this is kind of an
interesting idea
three kinds of activity occupied the
minded worlds in this phase of galactic
history the main practical work was to
enrich and harmonize the life of the
galaxy itself to increase the number
and diversity and mental unity of the
fully awakened worlds up to the point
which it was believed was demanded for
the emergence of a motive experience
more awakened than any hitherto attain
so you know
creating more and more diversity among
humans
what's the second he says the second
kind of activity was that which sought
to make closer contact with other
galaxies by physical and telepathic
study the third was the spiritual
exercise appropriate to beings of the
rank of world minds this last seems to
have been concerned at once with the
deepening of the self-awareness of each
individual world spirit and the
detachment of its will for merely
private fulfillment so we've got each
race is now contributing to an even
greater
project you could say the last thing
that i want to bring up here as well
you could say well there is at least one
exception or several exceptions to human
right and i think the staple that is is
fine with that there are these stars
which are
found to be
sentient and they have their own kind of
communication going on and the
human races within this galactic you
know union are able to
communicate with them eventually and the
stars themselves have to decide what to
do with these seeming parasites that are
messing around
with the galaxy
they even find what's called a stunted
cosmical spirit in the
great megatheria the nebuli
and
all of these are forms of life all of
these are forms of sentience they're not
all necessarily
men or human beings but they are
getting
connected with each other through
communication through a common life
together
into a
cosmos
and this brings us to you know we can't
cover every single philosophical theme
we would like to necessarily but this
brings us to
one of the grandest philosophical themes
that stapleton himself is going to think
a lot about over the course of his life
and encounter other people who are you
know talking about this
and weave it into
the very
history of the cosmos
itself
the quest you could say for
absolute spirit
another one of the great philosophical
themes is in the title star maker a
being that is capable not only of
creating
a star or a bunch of stars or the big
bang or the cosmos but
as we find out a hyper cosmos
something
that is an intelligent
beyond intelligence perhaps
entity that is bound up with the entire
universe and universes on universes
can be understood can be sought by
intelligent races and yet in some way
transcends them
and
you know there's sort of intimations of
this
in the you know last and first men for
example
um you know the last men who also you
know are kind of similar to the fifth
men in many respect um you know they've
got a kind of melancholy
thinking about the nature of the
universe that things are eventually
going to to wind down but that they can
access
all these
previous minds throughout space and time
the discovery says that past events were
persistent and accessible was for the
fifth men a source of great deep joy but
it also caused them a new distress right
and we have even more of that with the
18th last men who are realizing
that uh there's you know this folly in a
doomed world a community that was
yesterday the very flower of a galaxy
you know why are we persisting
in our efforts you know there's there's
that uh sort of thing going on and
they're thinking well what what caused
all this what's what's the point to all
of this right great are the stars and
man is of no account to them man is a
fair spirit whom a star conceived in a
star kills he's greater than those blind
bright companies for though in them
there is incalculab incalculable
potentiality in him there is achievement
small but actual right
and he says man was winged hopefully he
had on him to go further than this short
flight now ending he proposed even that
he should become the flower of all
things that he should learn to be the
all-knowing the all-admiring and
steadies to be destroyed so you know
human beings and the races of human
beings intelligence had the potential to
become something so much greater you
know masters of the
universe
well
in a way that's not needed because there
is indeed
a master of the universe who in star
maker is being called the star maker
right
and
he he goes on and um this is you know
the the narrator after they've gathered
a bunch of
mentalities to them and he says
it must not be supposed the normal fate
of intelligent races in the galaxy
is to
triumph um you know many humans uh many
other worlds of human rank uh were rich
in history but you know they had a
downfall right and he says i've already
said that as our experience of the
destruction of worlds increased we were
increasingly dismayed by the
wastefulness and seeming aimlessness of
the universe so many worlds after so
much distress attained so nearly to
social peace and joy only to have the
cups snatched from them forever
and he goes on and on here and he says
[Music]
the sustaining motive of our pilgrimage
going through space and time
had been the hunger which formerly drove
men on earth in search of god
yes we had one and all left our native
planets in order to discover weather
regarding the cosmos as a whole the
spirit which we all in our hearts
obscurely knew and haltingly prized the
spirit which on earth we sometimes call
humane was lord of the universe or
outlaw almighty or crucified and now it
was becoming clear to us that if the
cosmos had any lord he was not that
spirit but some other whose purpose in
creating the endless fountain of worlds
was not fatherly towards the beings he
had made but alien inhuman
dark and so
you know he talks about seeing religion
in all of these different worlds being
worked out
and this you know this is a
pessimistic point in it but later on
we're going to find that you know as
this entire
society
spanning the galaxy and going out to
other galaxies what he calls the
galactic utopia
is uh developing
that um
they begin
well they continue and they deepen their
search
for this
great being who started it all
here is in chapter
10 a vision of the galaxy it seemed to
us now the troubles of the many worlds
of this galaxy were at last over that
the will to support the galactic utopia
was now universal and that the future
must bring glory after glory we felt
assured of the same progress in other
galaxies in our simplicity we look
forward to the speedy the complete and
final triumph of the striving spirit
throughout the cosmos we even conceived
that the star maker rejoiced in the
perfection of his work using such
symbols as we could to express the
inexpressible we imagine that before the
beginning the star maker was alone and
for love and for community he resolved
to make a perfect creature to be his
mate we imagined that he made her of his
hunger for beauty and his will for love
but that he also scourged her in the
making and tormented her so that she
might at last triumph over all adversity
and thereby achieve such perfection as
he and his almightiness could never
attain the cosmos
we conceived to be that creature
and it seemed to us that we'd already
witnessed the greater part of cosmical
growth
and there only remain the climax of that
growth the telepathic union of all the
galaxies in order to become the single
fully awakened spirit of the cosmos
perfect fit to be eternally contemplated
and enjoyed by the star maker
so what do we have going on here let's
take a pause for just a moment in the
narrative you know we have this
incredibly complex galactic civilization
that has developed that is able to like
see into the past and to you know
recuperate what is good from it uh
incredible sensitivity of emotion
uh a utopian world in which the things
that are separating us and not just
separating us human beings of the
present but also the human beings
throughout the cosmos
have been
overcome
a very you know
blissful state you could say but a very
active state
well stapleton himself
admitted to being influenced by
benedict spinoza the
great you know
um
rationalist philosopher uh pantheist uh
in a certain respect
who you know wrote the ethics and a
bunch of other interesting uh treatises
as well and who argued that there was
only one substance and that is god or
nature and we are all merely
modes of it and this is you know a
philosopher that has captivated many
people's minds for uh centuries still
does today but you know i have to say on
the whole spinoza's
viewpoint on this is much less dynamic
than another great thinker coming you
know a little bit later on well actually
over a century
and a half later on hegel uh george
friedrich wilhelm hagel who conceives of
all of human history as being the
development of geist consciousness mind
spirit you know and uh you know thought
that that
we had been developing essentially into
whatever god was supposed to be
here on earth through our history
through um
all the
you know
previous struggles and trials that had
produced some advances dialectically
i would say stapleton actually goes
beyond both of those thinkers in how
he's conceiving of this and it's
interesting you know hegel uh hegel so
spinoza has goddard nature and he
doesn't really talk about you know other
worlds or anything like that hegel it's
this world and human history has been
developing and it's a very eurocentric
perspective that he has as well you know
it's been developing in the west and
basically we're all done now we just
need to make things more rational
stapleton thinks that this
is only going to happen i mean worlds
can have world spirits he actually uses
that name in star maker
but we need to have more than a world
spirit we need to have spirits of much
larger communities that include all
sorts of rational beings
even the stars themselves as we're going
to find and the end of the book
once we get past the incorporation of
the stars is a very long discussion
about
the star maker right and um you know how
the star maker
works and he tells us
that um
you know the the as the human author of
the book i have a difficult time
describing this but he goes into you
know page after page actually quite a
quite a few
uh talking about the supreme moment of
the cosmos i is the cosmical mind seemed
to be confronted with the source and
goal of all finite things i did not of
course in that moment sensuously
perceived the infinite spirit the star
maker
but what i did perceive was its presence
and he says it seemed to me
that i now saw the star maker in two
aspects as the spirit's particular
creative mode that had given rise to me
the cosmos and also more dreadfully
as something incomparably greater than
creativity
namely as the eternally achieved
perfection of the notice the use of the
term here
absolute spirit
which is the term that hegel uses in his
works right and there were a lot of
british hegelians that stapled and was
in contact with as a matter of fact he
criticizes them in his uh
theory of ethics book that he writes
early on
so he's incorporating this though into
the star maker and i'm not going to ruin
for you
all the
discussions that he goes into you know
about about creation
and the many different creations that
are taking place but i will tell you
that there's you know this division into
immature creating uh you know the very
first attempts and then there's uh later
on after a whole bunch of interesting
things mature
creating right
and he goes he sort of ranges over a
number of different creation ideas or
or myths remember too you know stapleton
is trying to create myths
in here
and um the star maker in the mature
creating
creates
all sorts of things that go beyond just
creating
a
cosmos
right he creates
um creations that can be intelligent
uh he creates as he says
many strange forms of time
um
and you know all different ways in which
beings can be connected with each other
can be related to each other can be
conscious of each other and of the
universe and it ends
by talking about is this a chapter the
ultimate cosmos and the eternal
spirit
so he said in vain my fatigue my
tortured attention strained to follow
the increasingly subtle creations which
according to my dream the star maker
conceived cosmos after cosmos issued
from his fervent imagination each one
with a distinctive spirit
infinitely diversified each in its
fullest attainment more awakened than
the last but each one less
comprehensible
to
me at length so my dream my myth
declared the star maple star maker
created his ultimate most subtle cosmos
for which all others were but tentative
preparations of this final creature i
can say only that it embraced with its
own organic texture the essences
of all predecessors and far more besides
it was like the last movement of a
symphony which may embrace by the
significance of its themes the essence
of the earlier movements and far more
besides and he calls this a metaphor
that extravagantly understates the
subtlety and complexity of the ultimate
cosmos
i would say that this is actually what
what hegel was groping towards in his
talk of the dialectic and sublation or
auf heimong
and this progression of mind developing
itself through all of
history so stapleton is in a certain
respect through through the the use of
narrative and imaginatively projecting
aeons into the future but but peopling
it with not just you know many many
million years hence peopling it with a
narrative
is accomplishing what it was that
thinkers like
hegel and his you know british
idealist successors
were trying to figure out and stapleton
is is providing these
to us as what he's calling myths as
something that we could be
working towards
and um you know this is he's not saying
dogmatically that there is a star maker
or anything like that but he is kind of
saying that if there is going to be a
star maker and it's going to be as great
as we could possibly conceive this is
what it would have to look like
so this is a fitting place i think to
end these discussions of these two great
novels by ola stapleton the last and
first men
and
star makers
you